so the question is how can I help that's
a great question and what we've done
with the young global leaders global
redesign initiative task force is that
we have 32 initiatives that were trying
to make gain momentum here at Davos and
you can go to our website and look at it
at redesign our world.com redesign our
world com and there are so many
different great ideas that the white
girls have come up with when within
values within health sustainable
economies strengthening economies
governance so please check out the
website I think there's many things you
can do on the local level depending on
your skills your interests your passion
the most important thing I think is your
passion what you really want to see
getting done in the world so good luck
and thank you for your contribution